President Trump is about to take center
stage at the World Economic Forum in
Davos the president arrived in
Switzerland this morning he plans to
meet today with the Prime Minister's of
Britain and Israel but his off-the-cuff
comments yesterday about cooperating
with special counsel robert muller for
hovering in the background the president
says he's quote looking forward to
talking to Muller and he would do it
under oath Margaret Brennan is with the
president in Davos with how he's
bringing his America first agenda to
Europe Margaret good morning good
morning well the president's message
here will be that the u.s. is open for
business he will tout his recent success
at lowering the corporate tax rate down
to 21% and urged CEOs to invest in
America
yesterday he discussed the possibility
of sitting for an interview with special
counsel robert muller regarding that
ongoing russia probe president trump
touched down in Switzerland Thursday
morning to sell his business friendly
approach to investors gathered at the
World Economic Forum on Wednesday he
told reporters that he'd be willing to
be questioned by special counsel robert
muller mr. trump's lawyers are still
negotiating details including the date
he did not commit to the interview but
said he was open to speaking under oath
last week White House lawyer Ty Cobb
told major Garrett he had concerns about
such an interview you have any fear of a
perjury trap no but I think it'd be I
think it would be foolish to you know
not proceed without considering that
possibility
the president also denied attempting to
obstruct the FBI probe and raised
concern about the political affiliation
of the deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
the president claimed he did not recall
asking McCabe who he voted for in the
2016 election sources told CBS News that
the president did indeed ask that
question and that McCabe replied he had
not voted
while he was never invited to this
gathering of the business elite back
when he was in real estate President
Trump is one of the most anticipated
guests at this forum today he'll meet
with the UK prime minister and his
friend the Israeli prime minister he'll
also have a one-on-one tomorrow with
Rwanda as president that may offer a
chance to clean up any fallout from his
reported derogatory comments about
African migrants John Margaret Brennan
in Davos thanks